do you think there's a reason why the
dynamic among current players has
changed to be a little bit more
sensitive if you've never been that good
and you got a podcast now and you
talking greasy that'll never be taken
respectfully like some of these C
podcast I'm like come on bro like don't
talk like you was that guy I was that
guy I can talk like this if I'm not that
guy I'm not going to talk like I was
that guy if I mention your name it means
I love you and respect you like I used
to love Dwight he did something I
couldn't do I wish I could jump that
high I love DWI heart a lot of people
don't know this my first time saying it
but as a big brother I ain't going to
let my little brother slide so I want
you to be better than me so like a lot
of people who don't understand this
thing of ours they think it's it's hate
no it ain't hate I'm telling you how to
get here you know I'm here dog I'm
telling you how to get here if you don't
want to get here that's on you and
that's why I kind of had to like you
know lay off them a little
[Music]
bit